all I know is what I've read some two or
three sentences that was in some report
that came out overnight and I since I
don't know anything more about than just
what I read that's all I can say at this
point all I know is what I read and I
wouldn't make any judgment of it until I
had more information well Senator Dianne
Feinstein put out a cryptic statement
today about information she received
apparently about Judge Brett Kavanaugh
the New York Times writing to officials
familiar with the matter say the
incident involved possible sexual
misconduct between judge Kavanaugh and a
woman when they were both in high school
the information came in a letter and
included the allegation of sexual
misconduct were the letters author a
person familiar with the letter
confirmed with this let's bring in our
panel
Charles hurt opinion editor for The
Washington Times any walter national
editor for the cook Political Report in
matthew cottan eddie editor in chief of
the washington free beacon we don't know
what we don't know but she has passed
this senator Feinstein has to the FBI
she's had according to sources this
letter since July Charlie it's coming
out today thoughts I guess in a weird
way we shouldn't be surprised because I
feel like Democrats have sort of trotted
out every single possible strategy that
they could come up with to block this
nomination and this is just sort of the
the strangest and I think probably the
most desperate and I have a hard time
seeing how it is effective at doing
anything other than you know alienating
you know independent voters that might
otherwise be interested in the Democrat
and we should point out the background
check for Supreme Court nominees is
vigorous FBI scrubbing essentially going
all the way back and that so it is so
hard because we don't there's so much we
don't know about about what this is it
does feel somewhat like we're back in
1991 with the Clarence Thomas hearings
right where they went through the
process and then there's a last minute
witness that comes forward of course
that's Anita Hill so there's some that
feels somewhat familiar in that sense of
course we don't know when we're going to
get to this point and I guess the
question then if
we if the FBI says we got it we're
looking into it and the Senate and
Senator Grassley says we're gonna take a
vote how much our Dems going to push
back on this and say absolutely not we
have to wait until we get the FBI to
clear all of this are they going to be
willing to do that and are some of those
red state Democrats willing to join the
other Democrats and putting that for
this could potentially gum up at least
the works moving forward let alone
threaten the nomination you would likely
see judge Cavanaugh addressed this at
some point but we don't know what it is
look I think the Democrats strategy has
been clear since day one when they began
interrupting the hearings they want to
delay the vote they wanted to lay this
nomination hopefully passed from their
point of view past the election and then
if the Democrats have a good election
then they can say well look we delayed
him to this point we just won the
election we shouldn't seat him at all
this has been the strategy from day one
we'll follow it to tweets from the
president really getting a lot of
attention today 3,000 people did not die
in the two hurricanes that hit Puerto
Rico when I left the island after the
storm had hit they had anywhere from 6
to 18 deaths time went by it did not go
up by much than a long time later they
started to report really large numbers
like 3,000 this was done by the
Democrats in order to make me look as
bad as possible when I was successfully
raising billions of dollars to help
rebuild Puerto Rico if a person died for
any reason like old age just add them to
the list bad politics I love Puerto Rico
interestingly two Republicans running in
Florida put out statements Rick Scott
running for Senate says said I disagree
with @potus
an independent study said thousands were
lost and governor Rosello agreed I've
been to Puerto Rico seven times and saw
devastation firsthand the loss of any
life is tragic and the extent of lives
lost as a result of Maria is
heart-wrenching I'll continue to help
Puerto Rico Ronda scientists put out a
statement Rhonda Sanders has committed
to standing with the Puerto Rican
community especially after such tragic
loss of life he doesn't believe any loss
of life has been inflated significant
maybe more so with Rhonda Santas who ran
as the Trump iasts of Trump candidates
who is looking at the politics of Puerto
Rico
Florida perhaps Governor Rick Scott who
spent a great deal of time as governor
welcoming Puerto Ricans and doing
outreach to the Puerto Rican community
because again just from a raw political
perspective Democrats saw the Diaspora
as they were coming into Florida
specifically in and around Orlando and
said these are folks that we can put
onto the voter rolls and they'll be very
good consistent Democrats Rick Scott has
been doing a great deal of work and
trying to win those voters over this
doesn't help from just a forget the
political perspective but if someone in
your family died in Puerto Rico or any
human being that dies and then to have a
president tweet something out that says
well that didn't really happen it was
really done to make me look bad that's
not a very Charlie he does step on
himself on these things to to push back
hard you know he could have said FEMA
according to the GAO the longest
response in the history of FEMA in
Puerto Rico three times bigger than
Harvey Irma and the wildfires combined
could have said that sure and but you
know what he said about the numbers that
is correct when he left at that time the
numbers were you know and and they were
revised upwards you know six months
later and then a year or more later you
know we can debate about whether or not
he should do that whether it's a smart
political thing to do but Donald Trump
isn't the person who politicized what
the weather that's been going on for a
long time and it's a day and it's a
dangerous thing to politicize this stuff
and and I think it's very harmful
you know harmful over the country I have
this doesn't help anyone especially
those two candidates in Florida it's not
the end of this I'm sure